[Music]
can you tell the difference between ps4
Xbox one and PC just by looking at the
graphics with all the excitement that
erupts every time a developer utters the
words resolution frame rate or heaven
forbid upscaling
you taught that these differences would
actually matter to the point that we the
humble gamer could spot them now if you
watch a graphics comparison video where
the footage is labeled and lined up side
by side then sure there is usually a
clear difference in the quality or look
of the visuals but then this is a
graphics comparison a video designed to
highlight these differences but what if
we were to strip all of that away and
create a blinded test where the only
difference players could see between the
machines was the graphics themselves
could people still tell their Xbox ones
from their ps4s and from their gaming
PC's well that's exactly what I did for
this week's reality check plus at the
end of the video there's a chance for
you to get involved and take the test
too I'll explain how that works and
exactly how my six test subjects fared
in just a minute but for now let's just
say that the experiment didn't exactly
make me many friends ok your dick it's
true I am let's find out why
my goal was to create three identical
gaming setups the only difference being
the machine behind the curtain quite
literally actually I had the ps4 Xbox
one and gaming PC from view behind a big
black curtain so first off displays say
hello to the 27-inch Asus VG 2 7 8 H II
monitor in fact say hello to three of
them they were kindly donated to us for
the test by Asus and they boast 1080p
resolution on 144 Hertz refresh rate
pretty much ideal for gaming as well as
being perfectly suited for showing off
the higher framerate of our gaming PC
and speaking of which here is the PC in
question the innards of this beast
consists of an Intel Core i5 3.4
gigahertz processor 16 gigs of RAM and
an NVIDIA GTX 780 Ti GPU but wait I hear
you cry surely this is a giant waste of
time as the Xbox one controller will
surely give the game away well don't
worry I thought of that don't call me
Shirley
this little box of tricks solved that
particular problem I call it the
cronusmax because that's its name it
allows you to plug your Dualshock 4 pad
into almost anything very handy ok just
one more issue to fix the dreaded button
prompts my workaround for this in the
end was significantly more low-tech
yep that's a whole bunch of black tape I
began the experiment by explaining to my
6 volunteers that they would be asked to
play the same game on the three
different gaming setups and then see if
they could tell which was which oh and
that they would do this three times once
for far cry 4 once for Call of Duty
advanced warfare and then finally for
Assassin's Creed unity simple right
here's what they said when I asked how
they thought they might get on hopefully
badly because you'd hoped that by now
this generation of consoles has come to
a point where it can match up to the
latest PC hardware I really don't think
I'll be able to tell the difference I
think I might be able to save somethings
PC but honestly I don't think there's
that much difference the ps4 and Xbox
one
I think I'll do pretty well I'm pretty
confident I've played a lot of video
games in my time so you'd think I'd be
able to tell the difference I would
imagine I would perform quite badly when
I game I just get involved in the game
and a storyline of what I'm doing and
don't really focus that much on frame
rates and this stuff so which i think is
that's going to be the thing that will
make me tell the difference I think I'll
probably get the PCU on pretty easy but
the two consoles pretty poorly if I'm
honest because I usually game only on a
ps4 so yeah I'm kind of a blank slate
for you
all right mixed levels of confidence to
be sure well let's see how they
performed starting with mr. blank slate
himself ex car presenter extraordinaire
and longtime gamer Alex go now Alex
thought that set up a was the Xbox one B
was a ps4 and C was the PC I asked him
why in particular the final one stood
out as the non console monster it looks
shinier it looks smoother it just it
just looked a little bit more polished
whereas I know like well consoles look
amazing you can't really beat PC for
super shininess and to my admittedly
broken eyes a little bit you got zero
out of three victory hmm so not a great
start there but what about gain spot
zones Sarah Lynch I was trying to look
at the markers that people generally
look at in these situations
sexy water foliage I thought I'd fail
the test and presume I have so in that
sense it's fine but I think the really
important point is it doesn't matter
what it looks like because I had fun
with guns and bullets well it's a good
job she did because she scored one out
of three successfully guessing appears
for bit mixing up the PC and Xbox one
some of our subjects did nail the test
though in fact X cars drew in CNET's
Lucan and they all got 100% the key
seemed to be that these guys all picked
up on the differences in the PC in
particular the framerate good reasoning
there and how did they react to getting
three or two three Hey
yes yeah they were pretty happy so at
the end of the first experiment only
half of my test subjects passed with
flying colors not exactly comprehensive
but at least it's better than random
chance which would have given us one
correct answer just by luck alone the
next test however didn't go so well
only two of our test subjects accurately
predicted which machine was which when
playing Call of Duty advanced warfare
CNET video producer mark was a victor
this time and once again the Laughing
Scotsman yes drew well done everything
changed however on the final test and
this is where we get to explaining this
this near dick you see the final game
was Assassin's Creed unity this time
around I did what's called a control
test all machines behind the curtain
were actually playstation force that's
right three identical setups now I
obviously didn't mention this little
detail to our volunteers so let's see
how they got on I felt that what I think
is the PC had a jump in frame rate which
is why I've gone with that one being the
PC the overall rendering on the one I
think is the Xbox seems to be the most
covering up its tracks that it seems to
be the smoothest nothing stood out
graphically but gameplay wise one of
them how can it so that was my main
focus I felt like there was a very
strong difference between all three yeah
they did listen as soon as I picked it
up noticeable I'm not sure I quite have
the language powers to articulate
exactly exactly what was different but
they just had a different feel not
necessarily worse or better but
different so how did they react when I
confessed the truth well I guess you
could say that drew was surprised I'd be
really surprised if he told me they're
all ps4 or ps4 they're all ps4 I'm
really surprised
Luke was them well cam you played with
my mind like it's a toy they're all ps4
no way and Sarah your dick oh yes I
remember now
so in the end test three completely
fooled to my test subjects and to seeing
differences whether we're actually none
while the rest of the volunteers didn't
really see any changes but they still
ever guessed that they were all actually
identical so what does it all mean well
maybe nothing because six people is
really far too small the sample size to
draw anything meaningful but it's fun to
note that the subjects who perform best
in the first two tests were also the
easiest to fool in the control study
which makes me think about how much of
our assertions about visual quality
might be down to our own preconceptions
about what we're expecting to see this
could perhaps be based on predisposition
towards our machine of choice our desire
to justify years of loyalty to a brand
or even what we've read in the media
about resolution differences ultimately
though the fact that my group failed to
ace the test does raise the question of
how much does this all really matter the
small graphical differences I mean and
now it's your turn in a few seconds I'm
gonna play three clips of far cry 4 back
to back one for ps4 one for Xbox one and
one captured on our gaming PC see if you
can tell the difference under controlled
conditions you can vote at the link on
screen now or by following the link at
the top of the comments on gamespot or
in the description on youtube oh and if
you want to avoid all the web
compression which will certainly make
this more difficult just follow the link
on screen now to my blog where there are
download links to the uncompressed files
I promise they're not viruses probably
make sure you come back in two weeks
time to find out the results and if you
want to let me know your thoughts on
this video leave a comment in the box
below or hit me up on Twitter thanks for
watching
[Music]
Rjay my boy are you busy you don't mind
me calling you fantastic
[Music]